[Music]
pitch perfect 2 is directed by Elizabeth
Banks and stars Anna Kendrick and the
rest of the original cast of the first
film along with newcomer Hailee
Steinfeld and once again is a story of
the Barden Bellas and their acapella
group trying to win some sort of
competition but it's really about their
friendship and how they bond and you
might think Chris is this really the
movie that you should be talking about
like do you really want to see this
movie let's talk about that the first
film actually did surprise me I thought
it was okay and that's saying something
because walking into it I was like oh my
god why am I here this is gonna be or oh
it's actually not that bad it's okay
okay all right
do you know where'd that come from I
don't know that's just one of the
reasons I went to this movie because the
first one did surprise me and it
surprised a lot of people I also like
the cast
Anna Kendrick is very talented and I was
curious to see how Elizabeth Banks
directed a film because up until now all
she's really done is direct a segment of
movie 43 I can't see that title without
freaking out inside ooh
and as the movie started I was like okay
we're pretty much in for the same thing
we were the first time around and that
was a little disappointing for me but it
was almost like they were getting the
fans of the first film in the seat
staying in the seat with the first few
minutes of the movie being pretty much
the exact same because then once
everyone was situated once there were
some jokes once everyone felt like they
were in the mood of the first pitch
perfect film the film began to take
different directions it explored the
human characters a little bit more Anna
Kendrick got a job at this company where
she's interning for this music producer
and it started to take the characters in
a more compelling direction in the movie
actually won me over in the end the
reason I enjoyed this movie is because
there's a lot of energy to it Elizabeth
Banks did a very good job with her
direction she gave a lot of charisma to
this movie you could really feel the
excitement behind the camera and in the
camera because the cast all have
excellent chemistry with one another
despite the fact that rebel Wilson is
doing pretty much the same thing she's
making jokes at the expense of herself
for the most part the characters in this
movie are actually really likable
they're the best part of the movie by
far and one of the best parts of the
characters in this movie where the fact
that they have to find their voice again
because they feel like they've lost it
they don't feel like they have that type
of synergy that they had anymore and
they have to figure out how to get that
back again in that sequence well stupid
because they go to a boot camp why did
they go to a boot camp learn how to be
better singers yeah
the film explains that they have to
learn how to work together again so it
makes sense it just kind of silly I
guess but the whole movie is silly and a
lot of these characters just like the
first film are really just stereotyped
characters you have your token this your
token that and your token this and
they're all there the fact of the matter
is these guys just work so well together
they have such charisma they have such
energy and one of the best parts of this
movie is actually the person who plays
the music producer it's key from key and
Peele he was hilarious in this film he's
this very successful music producer he's
constantly downgrading his one assistant
and he actually was one of the funniest
parts of this movie I really thought he
did an excellent job he had a lot of
jokes that just didn't hit for me
certain story elements that were
incredibly cliched but the fact of the
matter is this movie's crowd is going to
love it if you are a fan of the first
film you'll probably have the time your
life watching this movie it has a lot of
energy the singing is great and the
characters are still really entertaining
for the most part save a few all-in-all
guys this movie did eventually win me
over in the end I'm gonna give
pitch-perfect to a b-minus I was
surprised the fun I have with this movie
and I think if you guys enjoyed the
first one you're gonna have a great time
with this one but if you didn't like the
first one I thought it was just kind of
okay he'll probably think this one's
okay as well which is pretty much how I
felt it's a fine film it's an enjoyable
film go have fun with it if you'd like
to power please I am begging you see Mad
Max fury road this weekend it deserves
all the money's it needs all the money's
in the world it deserves it it's
incredible it's incredible filmmaking
guys I also would like to let you guys
know that my promotion that I've been
doing over the past like five or six
months with shutterstock.com is still
going on this is a website that allows
independent filmmakers or any type of
filmmakers really to use stock footage
legally helicopter shots of LA New York
planes under the water all types of
things that it's way too difficult for
us independent filmmakers to get to have
stuff in HD and now 4k quality is
fantastic if you find something you want
you have an account use the code Chris
5:1
five to get 20% off that's Chris five
one five that's my gift to you guys if
your independent filmmakers take
advantage of that because it is
definitely a great tool for you guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I appreciate it as always and also if
you shared my Mad Max review on reddit
that did not go unnoticed thank you so
much for doing that that was really cool
of you guys I really appreciate that
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]